- [Instructor] Hello readers.
There's a famous Japanese movie
from 1950 called Roshomon,
which is about different perspectives
on a horrible crime scene.
This is a film for adults.
Definitely, consult
your parent or guardian.
But in the film, you witness four distinct
accounts from four separate people.
And each person remembers
what happened very differently.
The stories contradict each other.
And by the end of the film,
it's still not completely clear
who did what to whom.
Now, this raises an interesting
philosophical question.
What is the truth?
How does a person's perspective
their point of view, their background,
and their beliefs change the way
they interpret events or ideas?
As readers, it's our job to engage
with that question by reading
and synthesizing multiple
accounts of events.
When we read multiple accounts,
we grow closer to understanding
a fuller picture of what happened.
Now, we've talked before
about the distinction
between firsthand and secondhand accounts.
So in 1912, the Titanic sank.
Someone was aboard and survived
to tell their story has
a firsthand account.
A historian who writes an account
of the Titanic has a secondhand account
and can incorporate multiple perspectives.
But even among the firsthand accounts,
you can have wildly different stories.
Compare someone who was working
in the ship's boiler room
to a rich passenger in a fancy suite.
They would've had very
different experiences
of surviving or, ugh, not
surviving, a shipwreck.
And it's important to get in a range
of perspectives in order
to get that full picture.
If you ever watched any
kind of sports game,
you've probably seen
an argument like this.
That's a baseball player
arguing with an umpire.
Umpires and referees have one
perspective on a sports game,
"You were out!"
And the players have another,
"I was safe!"
They both saw the same event,
the same play, but they see it differently
because their perspectives
are so different.
Now, we can take this understanding
to the texts that we read.
Who's the author of a text?
What's their perspective?
And what informs that perspective?
The baseball player wants
to be declared safe,
the umpire wants to adhere to the rules
as strictly as possible,
but maybe there also an umpire
that likes to call players out
because they like having
that power over people.
Let's go back to the example
of the crime scene from
the beginning of the video.
Imagine there's been a car crash.
Now, below are two different accounts
of the same crash.
From the driver's perspective,
"I was driving along, hands on the wheel,
"eyes on the road, when suddenly,
"out of nowhere, this kid on a bike
"comes racing out in front of me!
"I swerve to avoid them
"and ran my car into this tree.
"It's the biker's fault
my car is wrecked!"
Now, here's the cyclist's perspective.
"I was biking along, in the bike lane,
"when I look over and
this driver is texting,
"not looking where they're going.
"They were weaving into the bike lane,
"so I moved out into the road
"to keep from being hit.
"They must have panicked
because they crashed
"their car right into a tree.
"I'm lucky the driver didn't hit me!
"They should pay
attention when they drive"
Same situation, very
different perspectives.
Now, if we only had an
additional eye witness
to tell us what they saw.
That might clear things up.
The more accounts you have,
the more confident you can feel
in the accuracy of the facts.
So ask yourself who's writing the text.
Are they a fancy
passenger on a cruise ship
or are they shoveling
coal in the boiler room?
Are they a baseball player
or a baseball umpire?
It is only by comparing multiple accounts
that we'll get to the bottom of things.
You can learn anything, David out.